A wise crack.
Jared,
again,
while you guys probably think of key and
Peele as the duo that gave us president
Obama's anger translator or the
visionaries that finally made an action
movie about a kitten,
they're also responsible for some of the
smartest comedy that's reasonably grace
the airwaves.
And while much of their success can be
chalked up to their unique and often
absurd characters,
they're true brilliance lies and they're
streamlined writing style and a
commitment to sketches that are as
funny.
He wrote town like Atlanta as they are
socially and emotionally true.
I thought I was going to need rope tie.
Oh you are.
And how do they tell that truth?
Well,
let's find out since nothing is better
than overexplaining a joke.
Welcome to this wise crack condition on
key and Peele and I guess there's sort
of spoilers ahead to really understand
what makes key and Peele so great.
We need to look a bit deeper and
discover the comedic philosophy that
informs their work.
And believe it or not,
these guys follow in the footsteps of
this guy,
the door through which you will.
For those of you unfamiliar that isn't
the Demon lovechild of Dan Harmon,
Alan Morin's,
Levoy Jijak,
that's del close,
a pioneer of comedy who still hugely
influential today,
but before we get into how key and peele
embody closest comedic philosophy,
we need to take a look at a little
comedy science.
While you probably don't associate
science with comedy,
who can better understand the success of
many key and peele sketches by
distilling them down to a core comedic
structure.
In this structure,
we start in a world with a built in set
of expectations,
which is then contrasted with an unusual
behavior and this behavior is heightened
and explored until you've pissed herself
from laughing so hard and other the
words comedy is arrived at through
exploring a behavior that breaks with
the expectations we have of a given
situation.
If we wanted to go full,
beautiful mind on this structure,
it might look a little something like
this.
Reasonable reality instead of
expectations plus unusual behavior and
or point of view multiplied by raised
emotional stakes plus an ending which
subverts established pattern equals
comedy bliss,
but enough comedic calculus.
Let's take a look at substitute teacher
as an example.
The schedule opens in a high school
classroom and environment that carries
with it a set of standard expectations.
Board students,
chalkboards books,
and a teacher trying to wield some
authority.
But all this changes when Mr Garvey
begins taking attendance.
The colon,
which they call a net.
No,
Jay Kuala here.
Yeah.
Uh,
do you mean jacqueline?
Now that we have are unusual behavior?
I he,
Mr Garvey's inability to pronounce
stereotypically white names,
things can really get cooking.
We get to see both the logic behind Mr
Garvey's frustration.
I'm the rail.
The rail along with the increasingly
terrified students as Mr Garvey
continues this unusual behavior is anger
increases while their fear.
This simple underlying logic is what
helps accelerate the comedy with each
move.
Once we see this pattern repeated a few
times were already predicting the next
move,
they're not messed up.
Hey Rod,
not to be bested by an attentive
audience.
This sketch ends by flipping our
expectations for once Mr Garvey gets it
right?
Timothy [inaudible].
Thank you.
Let's see how this pattern plays out in
some other sketches.
For example,
we expect to babysit babysitter to have
a quiet night,
but and unusual behaviors introduced
google guy,
guy I why milk
and this behavior gets emotionally
heightened.
Your in charge of me in my house.
All right,
can for forest,
it's time for bed with a last minute
reveal that offers a glimpse into the
comedic logic.
Hush baby forrest whitaker don't say a
word guy.
Guy was going to buy.
You were mocking bird
in another sketch.
We start with a fairly mundane setting
until we meet our unusual companions who
are intent on living there,
vigilante air marshal dream.
I tell you one thing,
if not 11th or to happen up on it here
plain.
Don't worry.
We got there.
The stakes are then raised well above
cruising altitude.
Yeah.
You know how mark and up that plane,
oh God.
And rather than fizzling out by running
the pattern to the ground,
we get a surprise at the end.
That reframes what we've just seen.
Of course,
we know that sketches that don't follow
this pattern can also be hilarious.
Who can deny the pure joy of will?
Ferrell's gyrating midriff.
I gotta have my cop out or the wonder
testicular double Entendre of Alec
Baldwin's baked goods.
No one can resist my schweddy balls and
hell,
even key and peele occasionally basket
in the purely absurd.
Oh,
there we go.
There we go.
Comedic structure is only half the
story.
While they're sketches are certainly
funny,
it's another element of their work that
ensures that they're also smart key
appeals commitment to finding
fundamental human truth in comedy.
This philosophy is not an invention of
key and peele.
However,
they both cut their comedic chops in
Chicago.
A city whose comedy scene is permeated
by this guy del close,
and while you may not have heard of him,
he's responsible for training a few
decent comedians and along the way he
helped write a book called truth in
comedy with Sharna Halpern.
That's become a Bible for comedians
around the world in its,
they are you that the best comedy comes
from mining the depths of human
existence and that this creates the
grounds for comedy that is both funny
and smart and idea that we see
everywhere in key and peele.
Oh and del close once claimed that a
coven of witches cured him of his
cocaine addiction.
This has nothing to do with comedy,
but I think it's worth noting.
This commitment to truth isn't exclusive
to Chicago Comedians as this emotionally
honest style has dominated recently from
the diner to the break room do the
streets of Italy.
Now does this commitment to truth mean
that good comedy always has to reflect
on real and truthful situations?
Hell No.
But while a post apocalyptic alien
invasion might not reflect the reality
of the world we live in,
sorry to anyone currently on acid,
the core comedic idea is still grounded
in something fundamentally true.
That key and peels characters can
instantly know who is an alien by their
reaction to blackness.
How did you know
C'mon redneck wants us to move into his
community us.
The friendlier the white characters are,
the more certain they are of their alien
nature.
Would you let me tell your daughter,
let's return to Mr Garvey.
What's the truth that makes this sketch
so funny for a start?
This sketch reverses the trope of a well
intentioned teach for America type out
to save a bunch of inner city kids.
This role reversal produces both the
immediate comedy of Mr Garvey's
mispronunciations and the socially
conscious fact that this is something
that happens to minority students all
the time except in that case it's more
uncomfortable than it is funny.
Wow.
Mr Garvey's reaction to a name like
denise and Aaron are hilarious.
Key and Peele are forcing us to ask a
more complicated question.
What if black teachers where as
culturally incompetent as their white
counterparts and thus we have a double
pronged comedic attack come for the
laughter and stay for the socially
conscious criticism.
The benefit of this mixture of comedic
structure and finding the truth is that
hilarious sketches can be found in any
area of life,
race,
religion,
the dark side of professional sports.
You name it,
and they often do so by relating to
personal experience and their first
sketch titled
Bay.
There's a focus on the tensions found in
black masculinity between being a strong
Alpha male and a committed partner.
I looked this woman,
you told me six 45 you said that this
sketch heightens the limits that to
friends will go to,
to keep up the facade of being a hard
ass,
getting further and further away from
their spouses in the process and the
interstellar lengths they'll go to to
maintain this facade,
represent the actual effort,
man we'll put into prove they're one of
the bros.
And of course this sketch highlights the
absurdity of this whole macho
performance.
This theme is also explored in the
expanded key and Peele universe as their
first feature film Keanu throws to
normal suburban black men into the world
of organized crime and drug dealing
where they have to impersonate to
legendary street assassins.
At one point we see the two main
characters performing a stereotypical
sort of black masculinity play Somnio
real quick.
And conversely,
we see some of the hardened gangsters
brought to tears by the music of George
Michael.
They use a similar strategy in the
sketch office homophobe where we see a
tense interaction between two office
space.
You can't handle hearing about how I'm
gay.
I'm sorry.
You just referring to your boyfriend's
penis as a baby's arm holding an apple.
What happened?
I looked like,
which leads to a serious accusation,
homophobic.
And while this sketch at first seems to
set up a tired trope in which the humor
is derived from a flamboyant gay
stereotype.
That's disgusting.
Oh,
I see.
So you don't want to see up close the
pitch of my anus cause you hate day,
man.
This expectation is ended when the
homophobes boyfriend shows up.
It's my boyfriend.
How are you doing?
I'm doing very well.
Which leads to a surprising realization
for keys.
Character.
I get it.
I'm not persecuted.
I'm just a APP.
And the truth of this sketch,
well no matter your sexual preference or
gender identity,
you can still be an asshole.
I'm more common source of comedic
inspiration has always been good old
fashion.
Religion and critiques of religion are
not new
when it comes to boots.
Big Time Major League.
You have to stand in awe,
in awe of the all time champion of false
promises and exaggerated claims religion
rather than following in the footsteps
of those who find comedy in skewering
religion.
Ford's irrational claims key and peele
find a much more human take on religion
and in particular Christianity.
The sketch opens with a group of earnest
believers in prayer and this group of
Christians is rewarded with a visit from
the voice of God himself.
However,
once God responds to their prayers with
some practical next step,
so whole
they become slightly less enthused.
Eventually they find a nice loophole to
avoid having to actually follow God's
command of service.
Oh,
sketch just so great because it offers a
funny critique of religion with some
genuine theological nuance.
The joke isn't on religion in general or
believers in particular.
Rather it points out the hub holocracy
of those unwilling to take their own
religious tradition seriously when it
comes to following through on a not so
fun obligation.
This critique is actually one founded in
Christianity itself.
As the book of James Famously says,
faith without works is dead.
Even your most devout onto couldn't
disagree with this one and even more
brutally honest social critique can be
seen in their sketch sound off,
which is set at basic training.
While we assume that the drill sergeant
is going to lead the song in some absurd
direction,
it ends up finding comedy in a place of
harsh realism from Port Orford and
Armando Uris Hall are from all families.
Cow Fall,
we roam,
sold the rich church can just,
Oh,
the sketch doesn't only point out the
disparity and who ends up fighting
America's wars,
but also the reality of what awaits
soldiers coming home from war.
When I come home with the kids when I
come home with PTSD,
the Va hospital,
somehow they managed to make a sketch
about economic inequality and inadequate
medical care in the military.
Funny,
while they have multiple sketches that
use the absurdity of football for
comedic fuel bootsie wow.
This,
he could call me todd royal,
wrapping up Russia like aluminum foil in
quarterback concussion.
They use the trope of the heroic
quarterback to shine some light on the
medical reality of the game.
After taking a big hit,
we see the quarterback go from confused
seriously about what do we do it too
quickly offering fictional baked good.
Oh,
you have to.
Joe was ass man has put an apple pie to
go around
for getting diagnosed by a teammate.
You have a brain injury.
You need to get some medical and same
suit
after seemingly getting it together in a
rousing chance of team spirit.
Quarterback notices a missing piece of
his identity as a rhino.
Oh my God,
somebody stole my heart
runs off in an effective parody of the
inspirational sports movie genre key and
Peele or showing us what it would look
like if these movies accurately
represented the horrific injuries
suffered by athletes.
While that's just a few examples,
keon peels five seasons plus Keanu are
filled with hours of insanely smart and
insanely funny sketches and because most
of their work is grounded in true human
emotions and situations rather than
topical humor.
These sketches really hold up but most
importantly key and peele serve as a
reminder for the greatness of the TSA.
I'm ts monk
so if you see any terry's trying to get
froggy,
you should always remember to correct
hell scow.
Thanks for watching guys.
Peace.
If you guys want to hear more,
we just released the first episode of
the wise crack podcast where we break
down every episode of this season of
Rick and morty.
So check the description to find out how
you can find our podcast on itunes,
soundcloud,
Google play,
or anything else.
Also,
we want to thank you guys for all the
support.
We love making videos for you guys and
really couldn't do it without you.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for everything y'all do.
Another way you can support us is by
becoming a patron.
You'll get immediate access to exclusive
patron only releases,
including podcasts on wonder woman and
Spiderman.
My video on daddy issues in guardians of
the galaxy part two and a new video on
the possible medic commentary behind
Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk.
And we're working on more patron
exclusive content each month,
including behind the scenes experiments
with new formats,
quick takes and more.
So I'll be sure to check out our patrion
page at the Lincoln and description.
Don't forget to subscribe and ring that
bell to always be in the know on what
we're up to.
Thanks y'all.
He's.